ARRIVE SO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
VERY PLEASED THAT WE CAN GET-
THE QUICK START THIS MORNING SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS
SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS- AND- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. DR
COURT HERE DR COURT HERE. VICE
CHAIR SMITH. HERE. DR ARAMBULA
HERE. BARRICADE HAND. DALLI
DALLI HERE. CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HERE. HOLDEN
MATHIS WHAT A TO G. WE HAVE
FIVE MEMBERS WONDERFUL SO GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE
HEARING. WE'RE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SCENE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE WILL WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCHING
PARTICIPATE. IN PERSON ON THE
OTHER HAND IT SHOULD BE MORE
THAN WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST.
SINCE WERE PARTLY OPEN RIGHT
NOW. I'D LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYONE TO MAINTAIN PROPER
MASK USAGE AT ALL TIMES. PLEASE
DO NOT REMOVE OR LOWER YOUR
MASCULINE SPEAKING VERY PRETTY
SURE YOUR COOPERATION. TODAY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- TO- WILL WE
HAVE A MINIMAL STAFF-
CONTINGENT. AND LIMITED NUMBER
OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA. SO WE
CAN MAINTAIN SIX WHETHER SPACEY-
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND
FOR THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM. BUT
NOW'S A GOOD TIME TO COME
BEFORE WE MEET BEFORE WE GET
OUR QUOTA FIVE HUNDRED.
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN THE
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. OVER THERE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME ALSO AS THE
PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE- YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING TO RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEN UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL- INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON TO TIME. THE EXPERIENCE
DISRUPTORS ROCKIN INCIDENTS IN
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS ANY
CONTACTED TO SHRUBS TO SERVE.
FOR OTHERWISE IMPEACH THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THE HEARING
IS PROHIBITED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WITH A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES
TODAY IN ADDITION TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. WE ALSO HAVE THE OPTION
OF TESTIFYING IN OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS- WE WILL
ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THROUGH
WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY
IN THE BILL. NOW LISTEN
CAREFULLY I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
THE NUMBERS TO CALL IN. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS YEAR
READ IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT NUMBER.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO I'M
GONNA REPEAT THAT. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR. TWO ZERO TWO-
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
CALLING AND PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON HIS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. OFTEN TESTIMONY
WILL BE TAKEN TO GATHER THAT
IS- THOSE IN FAVOR THE BILL IN
THOSE AGAINST- ONCE THEY ARE
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES HAVE
PRESENTED. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE LEMONADE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
REDUCE THE SOUND DISTORTION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF
YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST THE BILL
YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE LIVE
LINE AND WILL NEED TO MUTE
YOURSELF INTO YOUR CALLED UPON
TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE. THREE NINE SIX
FIVE AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
BE THERE TO HELP I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION A LETTER PORTHOLE ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH THIS AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL IN RESPECT OF THE WHOLE
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. FOR BILLS
ARE ON IT TODAY'S AGENDA AND
ONE BILL IS PROPOSED TO CONSENT
TESTIMONY IS LIMITED TO FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL FOR EACH SIDE PER
BILL ALSO AFTER THE PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT PROVIDE
THEIR TESTIMONY- I WILL FIRST
ASK FOR THE SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM I WILL DO THE SAME
FOR THE OPPOSITION AGAIN PLEASE
NOTE THAT PHONE TESTIMONY WILL
BE COMBINED FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. THEN WILL BE
TAKEN AFTER BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION PRIMARY WITNESSES
HAVE TESTIFIED WILL BE LIMITED
TO TWENTY MINUTES OF PHONE
TESTIMONY PER BL ALL ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
PLACE TO PLEASE STATE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE IN THEIR POSITION
ON THE BILL. I THANK YOU. NOW
WE WILL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO I HAVE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT- MOTION BY THE VICE
CHAIR SECOND BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
COMPRISED OF SB TWO FORTY FOUR
ARE TO LET THAT THE MOTION IS
DUE PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCES
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO
CONSENT CALENDAR. QUIRK HERE I
SHE'S ME YET HI CORK HI SMITH
SMITH I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I OUR
QUE HAN. DALLI DALLI I CRISTINA
GARCIA. CRISTINA GARCIA I
HOLDEN. MATHIS MURATSUCHI WE
HAVE FIVE VOTES THAT'S OUT BUT
WE'LL KEEP IT UP THANK YOU-
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO CONSIDER SB
THIRTY SEVEN CORTESE. ARE YOU
MAY COME UP SIR SENATOR-
CONTAMINATED SITE CLEANUP AND
SAFETY ACT THIS BILL DEALS WITH
CONTAMINATED SITES AS WELL AS
WITH SEQUEL. OVER HERE IN VOTE
ON THE WHOLE BILL OUR
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION IS ON
THE CONTAMINATED SITE PORTION.
THIS BILL IS DOUBLE REFER TO
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE WHICH DEALS WITH THE
SEQUEL ISSUE. SO WHAT WILL BE
ASKING THAT I'LL MENTION THIS
AGAIN AS WE FINISH USED TO VOTE
ON THE- WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
CONTAMINATED SITES RATHER THAN
ON SEEK WELL BECAUSE THAT. WE
DO NOT HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO
DEAL WITH THE SEQUEL ISSUE AND
THAT WILL BE DEALT WITH AND
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
OKAY SENATOR- DOMINIC CORTESE
WAS YOUR FATHER YES THEREFORE
IT IS REFERRED APPROPRIATE THAT
YOU HAVE A BILL UPDATING HIS
LAST PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY PLEASED TO SEE YOU TO
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH GREAT TO BE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
TODAY A PLEASED TO PRESENT SB
THIRTY SEVEN. A BILL THE
SAFEGUARDS PUBLIC HELP BY
PROHIBITING THE USE OF WHAT'S
CALLED A COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION
FOR PROJECTS LOCATED ON CORTESE
LIST SITES CORTESE LIST
ORIGINALLY- AS YOU JUST POINTED
OUT MISTER CHAIR CREATED IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES- BY MY FATHER
FORMER ASSEMBLYMAN DOMINIC
CORTESE IS A LIST OF
CONTAMINATED SITES CREATED BY
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF COMPILING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
OF HAZARDOUS MATERIAL RELEASE
SITES. STATE LAW CURRENTLY
PROHIBITS CATEGORICAL
EXEMPTIONS FROM BEING GRANTED A
PROJECTS IMPACTING SITES LISTED
ON THE CORTESE LIST BECAUSE OF
CONTAMINATION ON THE SITE POSE
A SIGNIFICANT RISK TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. HOWEVER THIS WAS
NOT BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
REVISITED. OF IN OVER A DECADE
AS A RESULT SOME LOCAL AGENCIES
HAVE SKIRTED THE LAW. BY
GRANTING EXEMPTIONS PURSUANT TO
THE SO CALLED COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTION ALLOWING PROJECTS TO
BE CARRIED OUT WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH ADEQUATE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW. PURSUING THOSE PROJECTS
WITHOUT PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
AND APPROPRIATE CLEANUP POSES
SEVERE HEALTH RISKS TO LABOUR'S
WORKING ON THE SITE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY THAT LIVE NEAR
THE SITE. AND FUTURE TENANTS OF
THE PROPERTY. SB THIRTY SEVEN
CLARIFIES THE LAW TO CONFORM
CONFIRM- THAT THIS COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTION CANNOT BE GRANTED FOR
PROJECTS ON THE CORTESE LIST
SITES. RIGHT NOW ALL OF THE
CONCERNS BROUGHT UP- BY
OPPOSITION THAT PROHIBITING THE
USE OF THE COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTION WOULD IMPLICATE
PROJECTS IMPACTING SITES THAT
HAVE RECEIVED A NO FURTHER
ACTION LETTER INNER DEEMED
CLOSED. WE ARE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS TO WORK TOWARDS A
SOLUTION ENSURING THAT.A SITES
POSITION ON THE LIST ITSELF
DOES NOT AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGER
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW IN ALL
CASES PARTICULARLY WHERE
THERE'S NO FURTHER ACTION
LETTER. APPOINT ANY OTHER
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WOULD
REQUIRE SEEK REVIEW OF COURSE I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS BILL IN
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS JAMES THEIR WACHTER
FROM THE STATE COUNCIL
BELIEVERS IN CHELSEA TWO FROM
THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JIM- I. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. SO LET
CENTER FROM MODERATOR CAN'T DO
WE HAVE JAMES THURBER WACKER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL OF LAB LABORS ON THE
LINE IF SO PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CARE- CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH MISTER CHAIR. YES I'M
GOING TO TURN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS JAMES
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA-STATE COUNCIL LABORS. WE ARE
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF SB THIRTY
SEVEN. AND WE ARE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR CORTESE'S
LEADERSHIP AND UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT ON THIS BILL. LABORS
ARE COMPRISED OF OVER SIXTY
THOUSAND UNION UNION WORKERS
STATEWIDE AND WE ARE IN TERMS
OF- MEMBERSHIP THE LARGEST
CONSTRUCTION UNION IN
CALIFORNIA. WHETHER IT'S
REPAIRING OUR ROADS AND
HIGHWAYS. OR IMPLEMENTING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MULTI FAMILY
AND MIXED USE PROJECTS. THE
SAFETY OF BOTH OUR WORKERS
MISTER ANY COMMUNITIES OF OUR
JOB SITES REMAINS A TOP
PRIORITY ONE THAT WE DO NOT
WISH TO COMPROMISE. SB THIRTY
SEVEN CLOSES A LOOPHOLE IN THE
SEQUEL REVIEW PROCESS THAT
OTHERWISE COULD PLACE TO HELP
AT RISK OF STATE WORKERS. YOUR
WORKERS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS-
TERRORIST. UNDER CURRENT LAW TO
SEEK WORK PROHIBITS CERTAIN
EXEMPTIONS FOR THE THOUSANDS OF
PROPERTIES ON A STATE WIDE
ROSTER OF HAZARDOUS WASTE THAT
CALL THE CORTESE. THESE
CATEGORICAL EXEMPTIONS ARE ONLY
SUPPOSED TO GO TO PROJECTS WITH
NO SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT OR TO HUMAN HEALTH-
THE PROHIBITION IS TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
AND FUTURE OCCUPANTS FROM
EXPOSURE TO DANGEROUS
SUBSTANCES. ET COMMONSENSE
EXACTING HOWEVER WHICH THE
SENATOR ALLUDED TO- IS ANOTHER
BLACK WITH BETTER TERM LOOPHOLE
THAT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVELY
EXPLOITED BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN RECENT YEARS.
THESE TYPE OF EXEMPTIONS
ENCOURAGE- FAST TRACK PROJECT
APPROVAL AND ALLOW CITIES TO
WHAT STATE REVIEW DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THESE EXEMPTIONS ARE
SUPPOSED TO APPLY ONLY TO THOSE
PROJECTS REPRESENT NO
POSSIBILITY. OF SIGNIFICANT
HAZARDS. IF YOU HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY BY HE CAN REVIEW.
IT WITH THIS MECHANISM. THE
FOURTEENTH REPAIRS AND SOME OF
THE MOST THREATENING HAZARDS ON
A CONSTRUCTION SITE ARE THOSE
THAT WORKERS CANNOT BE READILY
FEEL. HE HAD A DROP IN THE
RESULT OF CONTAMINATED SOIL AND
GROUNDWATER LEAKING UNDERGROUND
TANKS OR THE IMPROPER
MANAGEMENT OF WASTE MATERIALS
AMONG OTHER CAUSES. THIS BILL
SIMPLY CLARIFIES THE PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE TO PROVIDE ALL
EXEMPTION INCLUDING THESE
COMMON SENSE PROTECTIONS.
CANNOT BE GRANTED TO PROJECTS
THAT ARE NAMED ON THE
PARTICULAR. IF I COULD BRIEFLY
ADD THAT WE ARE VERY SENSITIVE
TO THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
PARADIP TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT NEW DEVELOPMENT
STARTED UNDERGOING
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING PROCESS
YOUR GUIDE YOUR TIME IS UP
YOU'VE HAD YOUR TWO MINUTES
UNLESS YOU WANT TO EAT INTO
CHELSEA TO THIS TIME. NO I
RECOGNIZE BE ACTUALLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR TALKING SURE.
OKAY NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM
CHELSEA TO ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE ON RACE POVERTY IN THE
ENVIRONMENT PLEASE PROCEED AND
WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. CHOCOLATIER AND I'M
WITH THE CENTER ON RACE POVERTY
AND THE ENVIRONMENT THIRTY
YEARS EUROPEANS WORKED WITH LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR TAP THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND STATE CAN
SHORT THAT BOEHNER WANTS ME
NEEDS CAN PROVIDE. A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT. WE'VE THAT HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT STARTS WITH THE
STATE AND HEALTHY HOME BUYERS
FREE FROM HAZARDS AND THAT IS
WHY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
THIRTY SEVEN. THIS BILL COLD
LOCAL AGENCIES TO THE
PRECAUTIONARY PRINCIPLE
ANYTHING NECESSARY TO PREVENT
FURTHER USE OF THE COMMONSENSE
EXEMPTION AND OTHER EXPANSION
BY LOCAL AGENCY. I THINK NOW
PEOPLE REQUIRED PROJECT
PROPONENTS TO ANALYZE PUBLICLY
DISCLOSE AND MITIGATE
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. OF THE PROPOSED PROJECT
I THINK THE PROCESS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LOCATING
SENSELESS MUSIC BACK HOME. ON
LAND THAT'S CONTAMINATED WITH
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS HOWEVER
ESCAPING ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
AGENCIES HAVE TAKEN AWAY THE
PUBLIC AND FUTURE REFERENCE
RIGHT TO LEARN ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AND HELP
MAKE IT SHOULD DEVELOP. YOU
HAVE TOXIC LAND. HI HAS ALSO
TAKEN AWAY THE PUB ABILITY TO.
THAT MAXIM CLEAN UP LEAST
ADEQUATE UP DONE TO. A PROJECT
IS APPROVED. SOME PROJECT
PROPONENTS NEED A CHECKS AND
BALANCES BUILT INTO C. CLASS IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE DO
NOT CALL IN THE FIRST PEOPLE
HEALTH IMPACTS TO THE FAMILIES
TO- LET. ME ABOUT MINUTES FOR
DECADES. THANKS CENTER COUNTRY
THE FOR BRINGING THE SPELL AND
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DIRECTOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
WE HAVE A WITNESS YEAR IN
PERSON WHO WILL GIVE HIS NAME.
OUR POSITION AND AFFILIATION
OFFENDING PLEASE PROCEED SIR.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- ANY OTHER WITNESSES
HERE IN THE ROOM. ARE ANY
WITNESSES ON- HERE IN THE
CAPITAL THAT WOULD SPEAK
THROUGH THE SCREEN IS SO JUST
START AND THE SCREEN WILL LIGHT
UP. OKAY I GUESS NOT SO NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TESTIFYING ON THE PHONE LINE-
JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JOHN KENNEDY I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB THIRTY
SEVEN WE FEEL SB THIRTY SEVEN
IS AN OVERLY BROAD BILL AND
WILL UNNECESSARILY INCREASE
COST AND THE WAY APPROVAL FOR
MANY TYPES OF MINOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY EXEMPT FROM
SEQUEL. AT THOUSANDS OF STATE
AND LOCAL FACILITIES SB THIRTY
SEVEN PROHIBITS THE USE THAT
SYNC WITH COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION
FOR PROJECTS UNDERTAKEN ON ANY
OF THE ROUGHLY FORTY THREE
THOUSAND FORTY DELASALLE RIGHT
ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND WHICH
INVOLVES LEAKING UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANKS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN REMEDIATED. THOUSANDS OF
STATE AND LOCAL FACILITIES ARE
ON THE COURT TO DELIST
INCLUDING LOCAL AIRPORTS FIRE
STATIONS POLICE DEPARTMENTS
CORPORATION YARDS AND MANY C.
H. P. CALTRANS CAL FIRE AND
STATE PARKS FACILITIES. COMMENT
EXEMPTION SB THIRTY SEVEN
RESTRICTS CAN ONLY BE USED
WHERE IT'S CLEAR THAT A PRODUCT
WILL NOT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT ON THE ENVIRONMENT. THAT
THE FOUNDATIONAL ISSUES EQUAL A
PRODUCT ISN'T SUBJECT TO SEE
WHAT AND WHAT THAT MAY HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT EFFECT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. THIS ISN'T BY
TAPPING SEQUENCE THESE PROJECTS
SIMPLY AND APPROPRIATELY AREN'T
SUBJECT TO SEE WHAT. THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS FOR WHICH THE
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION IS
TYPICALLY USED AND WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY SB THIRTY SEVEN.
INCLUDE EXTENSION OF THE
PREVIOUSLY APPROVED USE
PERIMETER SIDE OF GREUBEL
CONTINUATION OF AN EXISTING
LEASE REPLACEMENT OF AN
EXISTING ROOF INSTALLATION OF
SECURITY EQUIPMENT OR FENCING.
MAINTENANCE REPLACEMENT OF
EXISTING STRUCTURES ARE IN
TURKEY ALTERATIONS AND EVEN
PAVING AND PARKING LOT REPAIRS.
SO STRICTLY CONSTRUED SB THIRTY
SEVEN WILL REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO COMPLY WITH THE
QUOTE PERFORMING INITIAL STUDY
PROVIDE NOTICES AND ISSUE A
NEGATIVE DECLARATION. ASSEMBLY
REPAIRING OR REPLACING THE ROOF
AT A LOCAL FIRE STATION OR
PARENTS SECURITY FENCING IT MAN
MANY MUNICIPAL AIRPORTS. AFTER
TALKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
HEARING THE TESTIMONY TODAY WE
DON'T THINK THESE ARE THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THEY INTEND TO FALL
UNDER SB THIRTY SEVENS REACH.
WE OPPOSE THAT THE THIRTY SEVEN
BECAUSE IT'S OVERLY BROAD IT
WILL IMPOSE ADDITIONAL COSTS IN
PROPHECIES ON LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS FOR NO ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS. AT MANY STATE AND
LOCAL FACILITIES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS BUT MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. SB THIRTY SEVEN TODAY
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK VERY MUCH.
JUST ONE MINUTE FIFTY NINE
SECONDS EXCELLENT. SO THEN
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
MICHELENA BEHALF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA PLANNING
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATIONS
BURKE- MISTER LANE- PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BOB MICHAEL AND WHISPERED A
PUBLIC POLICY THINK TANK IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. WE ARE
COMPLETELY COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL AS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF NEIGHBORHOOD RESIDENTS AND
WORKERS. WHILE WE SUPPORT SUCH
PROTECTIONS SB THIRTY SEVEN AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN IS OVERLY
BROAD AND WOULD GIVE US A CALL
ON THE SEQUEL PROCESS AND
INCREASED TAXATION LAWSUITS
WITHOUT PROVIDING ANY
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION. WE HAVE
OFFERED A VERY TARGETED
REASONABLE SET OF AMENDMENTS TO
IMPROVE THE BILL AND ALLOW IT
TO ACHIEVE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
WITHOUT UNDERMINING HOUSING
PRODUCTION UNTIL SITES NEAR
JOBS AND TRANSIT. ECKLEY
IMPORTANT AS WE SIX DIRECT
DEVELOPMENT AWAY FROM HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES. WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE IT IS CRUCIAL
TO MAINTAIN A HIGH STANDARD
WHEN EVALUATING BROWNFIELD
SITES. OUR TARGET AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE OUTLINED OUR MODERN
HOPE YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THOSE WOULD ALLOW
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION TO BE
USED ONLY ONE. THAT THE QUARTET
THE LIST SITE HAS BEEN
REMEDIATED AND IS NOW CLOSE. TO
THE JOB INVOLVES NO SOIL
EXCAVATION. THREE FOR PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN CLEARED BY THE
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES. FOR
PROJECTS ON SITES AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH CALLIE PA
APPROVED PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
LOCAL REMEDIATION REQUIREMENTS
THAT MATCH OR EXCEED STATE
STANDARDS WE URGE THE AUTHOR
COMMITTEE. TO ACCEPT THESE VERY
REASONABLE AND TARGETED NUMBERS
TO THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR LAI- ANYONE
WHO IS IN THE ROOM WHO'D LIKE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE- WE HAVE SOMEONE
PLEASE PROCEED MISTER CHAIRMAN
MURS ALEX TORRES ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WAS BURNED
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION WAS
SUBMITTED THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
I UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE NOT
USING THE BIG SCREEN SO THE
NEXT THING WILL BE- THE
TESTIMONY ON THE PHONE LINES SO
PHONE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO SB.
THIRTY SEVEN. YOUR FARE AND THE
PORT ARE OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NORTH AMERICA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WE GET CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE UP TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU SHERMAN
BIRTH NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF THE
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MATT KREMIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE'RE HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO GO TO A LINE OF THIRTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DOESN'T
MATTER NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YIMBY WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND
ALIGNING OUR COMMENTS WITH. MR
LANE THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NEXT TO GO TO LINE TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF THEY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA THE ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE OF TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING- STOLE THE
OTHER BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR LONDON BREED- IN
OPPOSITION STILL FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IN MEXICO A LINE OF THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CATHERINE
DIED REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE
OF NURSES FOR A HEALTHY
ENVIRONMENT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
SINGLE LINE OF FORTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NICOLE
WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND JUST A
QUICK REMINDER IT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF S. B. THIRTY
SEVEN. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR EDUARDO
MARTINEZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO THEM FOR THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR- IT
WILL NEXT GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LET ME REMIND YOU. THAT
FOR EXAMPLE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
CBRE HAS SUGGESTED. WE DO NOT
HAVE THE- ABILITY GIVEN OUR-
CHARGE TO THIS COMMITTEE TO SAY
WHETHER THOSE ARE GOOD
AMENDMENTS OR BAD AMENDMENTS
THOSE WILL ALL BE LOOKED AT IN
NATURAL RESOURCES ARE WHAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT HERE IS
THE LIST ITSELF. THAT'S WHERE
OUR EXPERTISE SAYS AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND. ALL RIGHT WE GOT A
MOTION FROM WAS IT CRISTINA
GARCIA NO FROM MERIMBULA AND
THE SECOND BY MR HOLDEN- WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK THEM. OCT
CRISTINA GARCIA THANK YOU YEAH
I THINK YOU MISTER CURTIS YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I'M HAPPY TO SEE IT AND I DO
THINK IT'S FAIR TO UPDATE THE
LIST- AND SO GLAD TO SEE THAT
AND I DO HAVE COMMONSENSE
SEQUEL- WHEN YOU GET TO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE I'LL BE
RESPECTFUL OF. THE JURISDICTION
OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT IT'S LIKE
THAT FOR THE RECORD. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIMILAR. ANYONE ELSE
MISTER VICE CHAIR. WELL JUST I
KNOW IT'S NOT PART OF OUR
PREVIEW BUT MY CONCERNS I WANT
TO BE ON THE RECORD IS WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IF YOU CAN WORK
THROUGH THE THOSE ISSUES
BECAUSE AS A GENERAL CONTRACTOR
RETIRED IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
WELL HI BIRDS SOME COST FOR ANY
PROJECT BIG SPECIALLY WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH ON THE
LIST IT BEEN REMEDIATED BUT
THEY STILL HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THE SEQUEL SELECT A BIG
CONCERN. I THINK IT'S ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE WE'RE VERY
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY WE
WANT TO GO THAT BUT I THINK
IT'S STALLED THE PROJECT FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT WE NEED HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA SO FAR LOOK FOR TO
BE A MEMBER TO COME ABOARD.
VERY GOOD ANYONE ELSE. JOHN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY. I'LL
ALSO BE- OPPOSING TODAY JUST
SEE WHERE THE AMENDMENTS GO
THERE'S A HUNDRED- PROJECTS IN
MY DISTRICT BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL PROJECTS THAT HAVE YOU
KNOW THIS WILL AFFECT SO- I'M
INTERESTED TO SEE THE
AMENDMENTS AND- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE ELSE ARM SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- AS I NDICATED A
RELEASE ALLUDED TO IN- IN MY
PRESENTATION- WE DO UNDERSTAND
I UNDERSTAND AS A FORMER
SERVICE STATION OWNER OPERATOR
WHO DEALT WITH THE UNDERGROUND
STORAGE TANK LAWS- IN MY FAMILY
CONTINUES TO THIS DAY-
IRONICALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
IT WAS MY FATHER'S LEGISLATION
THAT CREATED THE REQUIREMENT
THE FIRST PLACE SO. INTIMATELY
AWARE OF THE ISSUES IN THE
STEPS AND WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF FRUSTRATION OUT THERE IN
TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENS WITH
CLOSE SITES THAT OUR LEGACY
SITES ON THE LIST AND WHETHER
OR NOT AS WE GET TO THE NEXT
COMMITTEE THAT'LL BE THE ISSUE
I THINK WHETHER OR NOT THOSE
SHOULD AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGER
SEEK WAY IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT ITSELF
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED. AND I'M
HAPPY TO REPORT AS OF YESTERDAY
PERFECT- IN PART DEALING WITH-
THE ACTUAL PLAN DEPARTMENT IN
MY HOME CITY SAN JOSE- WHERE
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE RUN
ACROSS- THOUSANDS OF THESE
CASES OVER TIME- THAT I THINK
WE HAVE AN ELEGANT SOLUTION IN
THE FORM OF AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL- BASICALLY NOT SAY THE
COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION IS IN
PLAY BECAUSE THAT WOULD SAY
THERE IS NO POSSIBILITY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT ON THIS
PROJECT GOING FORWARD EITHER
EITHER FROM. A RESIDUAL FROM
THE CLOSE SITE OR FROM THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT ITSELF-
THAT THIS IS NOT A FAIR
STATEMENT THAT THERE'S NO
POSSIBILITY OF ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT. SHORT CUT TO SORT OF
GET IT OFF THE LIST WHAT WE'D
MUCH RATHER DO IS HAVE AN
EXEMPTION THAT SAYS IF YOU'RE
CLOSE SITE- THAT THAT NO LONGER
WITH A NO FURTHER ACTION LETTER
NO LONGER AUTOMATICALLY TRIGGER
SEQUEL- AND THEN YOU'RE AND
THEN YOUR PROJECT GOES THROUGH
YOUR LOCAL PLANNING PROCESS
LIKE IT NORMALLY WOULD MAYBE AS
INITIAL STUDY MAYBE HAS A FULL
LIKE THE I. R. IF IT'S BIG
ENOUGH PROJECT- MAYBE IT HAS
NOTHING BECAUSE IT'S A NEW ROOF
ON THE BUILDING- BUT- BUT THAT
IT WOULDN'T AUTOMATICALLY- FALL
UNDER. YOU KNOW ANY OF THOSE
LEVELS ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
JUST BECAUSE IT'S ON THE LIST
WITH A NO FURTHER ACTION BETTER
SO WE THINK WITH ON FRIDAY WITH
A COUPLE SENTENCES THAT CAN BE
CLEANED UP- RATHER NICELY AND-
I JUST WANTED TO ASSURE YOU
KNOW THOSE WHO MADE THE INQUIRY
AND MADE THEIR STATEMENTS ON
THE RECORD THAT. WE'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING ON THAT AND FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WILL SEE THE BILL
AGAIN I GUESS EVERYONE WILL
EVENTUALLY YOU SHOULD SEE YOU
SHOULD SEE THAT SOLUTION THERE
SO THANK YOU AND AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS- THANK YOU SENATOR. I'M
GLAD YOU ARE. THINKING AHEAD-
GIVEN THAT THE THIS
CONSOLIDATED LIST WAS CREATED A
COUPLE DECADES AGO WITH. ONE
OTHER- SOLUTION TO THIS SO WE
DON'T HAVE- HOLD UP NECESSARY
HOUSING WHICH WE ALL KNOW WE
HAVE TO BUILD MORE OF WOULD BE
A MECHANISM FOR THE STATE
AGENCIES REMOVE SITES FROM THE
LIST. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THAT'S FEASIBLE OR NOT- BUT MY
STAFF IS WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND- ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE IF THAT IS
A POSSIBILITY. SO PLEASE- TALK
TALK TO MY STAFF AND SEE WHAT
WHAT CAN BE DONE OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF MONTHS- SO RIGHT NOW-
I WOULD. I'D LIKE TO
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE- WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. SO SOME
LET US PROCEED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SB THIRTY SEVEN CORTES AT THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES CORK. BY CORK HI
SMITH. SMITH NO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI OUR QUE HAN DALLI
DALLI NO CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MATHIS. WHAT A TO G.
SO WE NEED TO HOLD IT OPEN YES
ORDER SO WE HAVE FOUR VOTES WE
NEED FIVE- THIRTY THREE MEMBERS
WHO WERE DELAYED SO- JUST KEEP
AN EYE ON IT UNDERSTANDABLE
OPEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS APPRECIATE
THE CONSIDERATION. OKAY NEXT-
WE HAVE SENATOR DODD- MY
COLLEAGUES WHO IS WITH US IN
THE ASSEMBLY FOR COUPLE OF
YEARS- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND IN
MEMBERS- S. B. TWO TWO TWO
WOULD ESTABLISH THE WATER RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO HELP
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FOR BOTH
DRINKING AND WASTEWATER
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
RATEPAYERS EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS. AS SOME OF
YOU MAY RECALL IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN I AUTHORED LEGISLATION
AB FOUR OH ONE ASKING THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
STUDY THE ISSUE OF LOW INCOME
GROUP WATER RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM OR WHAT WE CALL LIRA.
THE BOARD'S DONE THAT IN SB TWO
TWO TWO TAKES THE NEXT STEP OF
MOVING FORWARD TO ENACT SUCH A
PROGRAM. IN ADDITION TO
COMPLETING THE WATER LIVER
STUDY THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD RECENTLY SURVEYED
HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS AROUND THE STATE TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH WATER DEBT
WATER SYSTEMS CUSTOMERS WERE
CREWING. THIS IS A SURVEY
RESULTS WERE VERY SOBERING HERE
ARE A FEW EXAMPLES OF HOW
SERIOUS THE PROBLEM OF WATER
UNAFFORDABILITY HAS BECOME.
OVER ONE AND A HALF MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS ARE BEHIND ON THE
WATER UTILITY BILLS THAT'S OVER
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE STRUGGLING
TO PAY FOR CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND WASTEWATER. 12% OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS HAVE A
DEBT OF AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND MORE THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND. OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DEBTS GREATER
THAN ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
CUMULATIVELY CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCRUED ABOUT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS A WATER DEBT AND THAT
NUMBER IS INCREASING AROUND A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PRE
PANDEMIC OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAD
ALREADY LOST WATER SERVICE DUE
TO AN INABILITY TO PAY WATER
BILLS. THAT NUMBER HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. GROWING WATER
THAT IS ALSO A PROBLEM FOR
WATER SYSTEMS SOME WATER
SYSTEMS OF LOSS AS MUCH AS 30%
OF THE REVENUE. AND MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THIRTY COMMUNITIES
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS ARE FACING
FINANCIAL COLLAPSE DUE TO THE
INABILITY OF THEIR CUSTOMERS.
TO PAY THEIR WATER BILLS.
CALIFORNIA HAVE LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR
ELECTRICITY AND NATURAL GAS.
NOT WITHSTANDING STATE POLICY
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER. THERE'S NO
COMPARABLE WATER RATES SYSTEMS
PROGRAM FOR PUBLICLY OWNED AND
COMMUNITY OWNED WATER SYSTEMS.
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE HAVE A STATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE
WHO STRUGGLE TO PAY FOR THEIR
DRINKING AND WASTEWATER. SB TWO
TWO IS A NARROW IS REALLY
NARROWED ITS FOCUS ON DIRECT
WATER RESISTANCE WATER CRISIS
ASSISTANCE IN RIGHT CREDIT. THE
BILL REQUIRES THE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP
AN EXPENDITURE PLAN. THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY THE FUNDING NEEDS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WELL I'M
GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR DO SOME
FOR PROPOSING ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF WATER WITH DEBT
RELIEF. THE TRUTH THERE'S THE
PROBLEM WATER ON AFFORDABILITY
FOR LOW INCOME. HOUSEHOLDS WILL
PERSIST. THIS BILL IS NOT ADEPT
AT IDENTIFYING A FUNDING SOURCE
FOR THE RAID SYSTEMS PROGRAM.
THAT IS A PARALLEL CONVERSATION.
IS BEGINNING TO TAKE PLACE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT VOTE
ON THIS CRITICALLY NEEDED
PROGRAM. ALL RIGHT MOVED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ARAMBULA DR
ARAMBULA THANK YOU- WE NOW HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
TESTIFYING ON THE PHONE LINE.
ARM SO JENNIFER CLAY ON BEHALF
OF CLEAN WATER ACTION- PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY CARE COURT AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER CLARY AND I'M THAT
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR FOR CLEAN
WATER ACTION OUR ORGANIZATION
IS A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND I
AM ALSO SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MY FELLOW SPONSORING
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER AND LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
OUR ORGANIZATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS SENATE BILL TWO TWENTY
TWO WHICH WOULD FINALLY PUT
INTO PLACE A FRAMEWORK FOR
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE LOW
INCOME WATER RATE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE OUR YEARS ADVOCATING
FOR SAFE DRINKING WATER TAUGHT
AT THAT MAKING WATER STATE IS
ONLY HALF THE BATTLE IF THE
HOUSEHOLD OUR COMMUNITY CAN'T
AFFORD THE WATER FROM THEIR
TAPS THAT WATER IS STILL NOT
ACCEPTABLE. THE WATERGATE
CRISIS GENERATED BY THE
PANDEMIC ALSO HIGHLIGHTED A
LONG STANDING PROBLEM AND THAT
DEVELOPED FOR OTHER UTILITIES
ARE VIRTUALLY NONEXISTENT FOR
THOSE STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
WATER BILLS ONLY ABOUT HALF OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION IS
CHAIRED BY PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
THAT OFFERS A LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
UNFORTUNATELY ENROLLMENT IN
THESE PROGRAMS GENERALLY
ABYSMAL LARGELY BECAUSE UP TO
EIGHTEEN REQUIREMENTS THE
RESULT IS THAT FEW ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS. ACTUALLY RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE. EXCEPTION ISN'T ON
UTILITY. WHICH HAVE HIRING ROLE
THAT IN THE WATER LINE PROGRAM.
THREE REASONS. ONE THERE MAY.
BY THE CAL PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION SURE THEY'RE NOT
SUBJECT TO PROPOSITION CHIU
EIGHTEEN INSTRUCTION AND THREE
THEY ALSO REGULARLY SHARE
ELIGIBILITY DATA WITH INVESTOR
OWNED ENERGY UTILITIES IS
LONGSTANDING AFFORDABILITY
PROGRAMS. AND ROLL MORE THAN
80% OF ELIGIBLE HELPFUL. MORE
AFFORDABILITY IS AN ISSUE IN
EVERY PART OF THE STATE SMALL
WORLD COMMUNITIES SUBURBS AND
URBAN CENTERS STATE ACTION IS
NEEDED TO PURCHASE
AFFORDABILITY GAP IN SB TWENTY
TO CREATE POSSIBLE INTEREST TAX
FRAMEWORK FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A STATEWIDE PROGRAM. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU. ON NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM. LAUREN A KIßM ON BEHALF
OF THE L. A. ALLIANCE FOR A NEW
ECONOMY ON THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU CARE
CORKING COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LONNIE CAMERON THE
WATER CAMPAIGN DIRECTOR FOR THE
LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR A NEW
ECONOMY A NONPROFIT FOCUSED ON
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL AND
RACIAL JUSTICE. OUR
ORGANIZATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL GIVEN OUR WORK AT
W. P. AS WELL AS I RESEARCH ON
WATER ACCESS AND HUNDREDS OF
WATER SYSTEM THROUGHOUT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. YOU ARE WORK WE
KNOW MILLIONS OF L. A. COUNTY
RESIDENTS ARE IMPACTED BY THE
COST OF THEIR UTILITIES. UCLA
STUDY ESTIMATES WANTED THREE
ANGELENOS HAVE WATER AND POWER
THAT AND THAT THIS IS UNDULY
BORNE BY LATIN ACTION BLACKS
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS. AND SOMEONE
COME TO REDUCE OF COLORS THIS
NUMBER JUMPS TO MORE THAN HALF
OF RESIDENTS WHO ARE AND THAT.
AND VERY CHARITY SPEND OVER
HALF A BILLION LED TO BE P.
ACCOUNTS ARE CURRENTLY AND THAT
WHICH IS TOTAL HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS. I TO
REPOWER ELLIE COALITION TOWN
HALL LAST WEEK RESIDENTS SPOKE
MOVINGLY ABOUT THEIR STRUGGLE
TO BE ABLE TO COVER ALL OF
THEIR BILLS INCLUDING
UTILITIES. AND HITTING BACK
AGAINST MEDICAL EXPENSES AND
SUIT. AND LADWP CUSTOMERS ARE
RELATIVELY MORE FORTUNATE AND
SO FAR IT'S PROBABLY DUE TO BE
P. HAS LOW INCOME PROGRAMS THAT
WERE GRANDFATHERED IN. BUT PROP
TO EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY SIX HAD
PUT SEVERE LIMITATIONS ON. THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THIS PROGRAM.
IN OTHER. OF THE- WE KNOW FROM.
ORG THAT THOUSAND OF PEOPLE OUR
CUSTOMER THE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS YOU DO NOT HAVE REPAIR
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS OF ANY KIND
AND THAT THE ARE OFTEN PAYING
EXTREMELY HIGH RATES FOR WATER
AS WELL SPACING WATER QUALITY
ISSUES. THAT EXISTING PROGRAMS
LIKE LIKE YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
ADDRESS RESIDENTS WATER THAT.
WE NEED SB TO HELP CONFRONT
THIS ISSUE AND ARE GRATEFUL TO
ALLAH IF YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR YEARS UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SENATOR DODD AND
THE BILL'S CO AUTHORS AND
SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. EXCELLENT IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I
SEE NO ONE- NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE MAIN OPPOSITION
WITNESS- CINDY TALK ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES-
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU CHAIR
QUIRK IN MEMBERS CINDY TALK
WITH AQUA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON SB
TWO TWO TWO WE AGREE WITH
SENATOR DODD THAT ANY WATER LOW
INCOME RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IT'S A GOOD IDEA FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
MOMENTS THAT SENATOR DODD HAS
MADE TO DATE. WE DO THINK THE
BILL NEEDS MORE WORK OUR LETTER
CAPTURES FIVE ISSUES AND ALL
NOT TO OPPOSE THIS MORNING THAT
ARE RELEVANT TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST IS- AS BACKGROUND THE
BILL WOULD APPROPRIATELY HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT
IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM. BUT THE
PART OF THE BILL THAT ADDRESSES
THE ADOPTION OF THE FUND
EXPENDITURE PLAN FOR THE
PROGRAM. PROPOSES TO HAVE BOTH
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT. IN
THE STATE WATER BOARD APPROVES
DEATH FUND EXPENDITURE PLANS.
SO WE SUGGEST THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO CONSULT WITH THE STATE WATER
BOARD ON THE PLAN BUT THAT THE
ADOPTION OF THE FUND
EXPENDITURES PLANNED SHOULD BE
THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF THE
AGENCY THAT'S IN CHARGE OF THE
PROGRAM AND THAT'S THE
DEPARTMENT- SO THAT WOULD BE A
SIMPLE CHANGE IN SECTION ONE
ONE SIX NINE THREE ONE POINT
ONE SUBDIVISION A- THE SECOND
ISSUE- RELATES TO A PROPOSAL IN
THE BILL FOR A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. IN THE DEVELOPMENT
BY THREE AGENCIES OF METRICS
FOR THAT NEEDS ASSESSMENT- WE
THINK THAT A GOOD LOW INCOME
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
CAN BE VERY EFFICIENT STILL
INSIDE INSTEAD OF SETTING UP A
COMPLICATED NEEDS ASSESSMENT
LIKE THERE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
THAT FOR SB TWO HUNDRED THAT
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THAT
PROGRAM WHICH IS VERY
DIFFERENT. IN THIS CASE- THAT
DEPARTMENT OR THE BILL CAN SET
A FLAT RATE BENEFIT FOR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AND WE'RE
EXPECTING THAT THIS PROGRAM
WOULD COME UP BENEFIT ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA BETTER IN THAT'S HOW
MANY ARE LOW INCOME HELP. SO
INSTEAD OF SPENDING. PROGRAM
DOLLARS ON ADMINISTRATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION FOR NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WE SUGGEST JUST YOU
KNOW FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT FLAT
RATE IS IN USE THE MONEY FOR
THE BENEFT IN OTHER WORDS THE
SUBSIDY. THAT WILL HELP THE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES- BEFORE THEIR
WATER BILL. SO WE IN YOU KNOW
BOTTOM LINE IS WE THINK THERE
CAN BE A GOOD PROGRAM HERE AND
WE THINK IT SHOULD BE
EFFICIENT. SO THAT- THAT CHANGE
WOULD BE DELETING SUBDIVISIONS
FEE OF PROPOSED SECTION. ONE
ONE SIX NINE THREE ONE POINT
ONE. SO THAT CONCLUDES MY
TESTIMONY AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S TURNING AND
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES
THIS MORNING THANK YOU. WELL
NOW IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION WHO'S IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM SAYING NO ONE.
ARE WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THE STATE YOUR NAME
OUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ONLY ARM. NOT MR-
PHONE OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN TESTIMONY. OKAY HERE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWO TWO TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF CENTRAL COAST ENERGY
SERVICES AND SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTED ADVOCATED IN OUR
SUBMITTED LETTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AN
EXCELLENT LINE OF TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
SURE NUMBERS NIKITA CRIED WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL TRACK RECORD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE ONE MARYLAND THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
ABOUT A LINE OF THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ASHLEY WALKER ON
BEHALF OF A LEAVING HANGING AT
THE COLD WATER DISTRICT A
HUNDRED JAM MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT. OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION FROM THE ATLANTA
COMMENTS WITH AQUA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANNEX OF A LINE OF
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING YOU'RE A MEMBER
STAFF MEANWHILE ON BEHALF OF
COUNTY TOOLS IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO
TO A LINE OF THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MORNING SURE
MEMBERS JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING AGAIN PAUL
YOUR ON BEHALF OF THE TULARE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
OR THANK YOU MEXICO A LOT. WHAT
THE LINE OF FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS BENJAMIN TRIED WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA I IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING BRIDGET CAMBIADO CERES
A SUSTAINABILITY NONPROFIT THAT
RUNS THE BUSINESS FOR
INNOVATIVE CLIMATE AND ENERGY
POLICY THE BICEP NETWORK A
COALITION OF MORE THAN SEVENTY
MAJOR BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES MANY OF WHOM HAVE
SUBSTANTIAL OPERATIONS ARE
HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OUR MEMBERS SUPPORT SB TWO
TWO TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOT SO GO LINE OF FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF
THE FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ON THE LINE OF TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
REBECA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I COULDN'T BALANCE WITH CLEAN
WATER ACTION ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY- CALLING ON
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NEXT OF A LINE OF FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JAMIE
MINOR ON BEHALF OF THE IN A
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS FROM AQUA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT OF A LINE OF
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANTHONY MOLINA
ON BEHALF OF MESA WATER
DISTRICT AND THE TOLD ME TO
LOSE DISTRICT WHERE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF UP TO FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF SAY THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF A THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CATHERINE DIED WITH
THE ALLIANCE OF NURSES FOR A
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SWEAR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
TO THE LINE OF FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAL
ARE NOT TAKING TIME OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE EAST VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT AND IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT- OPPOSED NORTH AMENDED
CONSISTENT WITH AWKWARD COMMON.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN A
DAVIDSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICT WE ALIGN OUR
POSITION WITH AQUA AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERSLESLIE
BASKETS HERE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TOM SCOTTO IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY ACTION PARTNERSHIP
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO IT'S A
LINE OF FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ERIC OREGON- YOU HAVE
TO COMMIT WATER CENTER AND
CALIFORNIA COASTER COAST KEEPER
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB TWO TWO TWO. THANK YOU NEXT
TO THE LINE OF TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THAT
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS GREG MORRISON WITH
ELSINORE VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT AND WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED INTO LINE OR
COMMENTS WITH CINDY TUCK FROM
AQUA THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO THE LINE OF FORTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
AXELSON TOWN I WOULD POLICY
THINK IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT HAVE A LINE OF THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DONNA THE LARA REPRESENTING
MOMENTARILY WATER DISTRICT HE
WAS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PLAN TRITON TRITON PRICE ON
BEHALF AT THE WATER FOUNDATION
AND NEXT GEN POLICY TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS NEED A
LABEL ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
FURTHER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
FOR A MODERATOR. I'M LET'S SEE
WE'RE FINISHED WITH TESTIMONY
AND WE THEREFORE WILL GO TO
MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR ALL.
HI I COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE
GOAL OF YOUR BILL- I JUST
WANTED TO- AND I APOLOGIZE I GO
HOME- FOR COMING IN LATE TO AYE
WELL AND IF YOU COVERED THIS
ALREADY BUT- I'M I'M LOOKING
AT- OFC WAS. OPPOSITION LETTER
AND- THEY'RE ASKING THE
QUESTION ABOUT- THE FUNDING
SOURCE FOR THIS PROGRAM AND-
AND IN THEIR REQUEST THE CENTRE
DIED- CLARIFY THAT IS NOT THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT TO FUND
THE PROGRAM WITH THE WATER TAX.
COULD YOU COMMENT ON THAT. YEP
THAT'S NOT THE INTENT OBVIOUSLY
IT'S STATE LAW YOUR BY BALLOT
INITIATIVE IS LIMITED IN THE
ABILITY TO- YOU KNOW TO DO THAT
SO- NO THERE'S BEEN NOTHING IN
THIS WHAT WE HOPE- YEAH WE'VE
GOT. I MEAN IT AS EVIDENCED BY
THIS YEAR WE'RE NOT ALWAYS
GOING TO GET A BILLION DOLLARS
TO BE ABLE TO BUDGET FOR THIS
TYPE OF SITUATION BUT CLEARLY
BEFORE. THE PANDEMIC WE HAD A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES IN THIS AREA SO- I DID
NOT. ASK FOR A- THIS THIS BILL
DOES NOT HAVE A BUDGET
AUGMENTATION TO IT AT ALL IT'S
NOT ATTACHED WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SET THE FRAMEWORK.
FOR THIS PROGRAM SO IT'S READY
TO GO FOR EXAMPLE. IF WE
ALREADY HAD THIS PROGRAM IN
PLACE IT A LOT EASIER TO GET
MONEY OUT. TO PEOPLE WITH THIS
BILLION DOLLARS AT IT YOU KNOW
THAT WE'RE DOING NOW. AND I
RESPECT THAT- YEAH OFF WAS-
YOUR SUGGESTIONS AND WE'RE
LOOKING AT THOSE WITH STAFF WE
WORK WITH THEM AND HAD A LOT
OF- YOUR MEMBERS BUT NOTE NOTE
NO WATER TAX. THANK YOU. MISTER
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD FOR BRINGING US FOR THAT
BUT THE DISCLAIMER AND I KNOW
MY COLLEAGUE IS A CO AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL. TWO AGO OVER THERE.
BUT MY BIG CONCERN IS EVEN WITH
THE- LETTERS OF OPPOSITION. BUT
EVEN SOME OF THE LETTERS OF
SUPPORT. STATE ASKING FOR THE
AMENDMENT. SO BUT LIKE TO SEE
THAT LANGUAGE GO FORWARD.
BEFORE I DO SUPPORT IT. AND AN
ONGOING FUNDING SOURCE HAS TO
BE FOUND. BECAUSE YOU CAN'T.
LOOK LIKE YOU JUST SAID THERE'S
NOT GONNA BE A BILLION DOLLARS
EVERY YEAR. AND THAT IS A COST
BUT- BUT MIGHT MIGHT FIGHT FOR
THE LAST SIX MONTHS SINCE I GOT
HERE IS WATER STORAGE WE TOOK
THE GOVERNOR TOOK A BILLION
DOLLARS. AND HAD WATER STORAGE
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD ALLEVIATE A
LOT OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
WATER SOURCE. IN THE LOWER COST
OF WATER SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
MAYBE YOU CAN WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR. THE THRONE OF THE
BILLION B. AND WE HAVE LOTS OF
BILLIONS AROUND RIGHT NOW FOR
WATER STORAGE. YES PLEASE
PROCEED. MISTER MATHIS THANK
YOU THROUGH THROUGH THE CHAIR-
CENTER DODD IT'S GREAT TO CO
AUTHOR OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION WITH YOU AND I
CANNOT EXPRESS THE IMPORTANCE.
OF GETTING THIS RIGHT OF
ENSURING. THE ABILITY TO
PROVIDE WATER TO SO MANY THAT
NEED IT- MANY OF YOU ALL KNOW
MY DISTRICT MY HOME TOWN OF
PORTERVILLE. IS SADLY
HISTORICALLY GLOBALLY KNOWN AS
THE CITY WITHOUT WATER- THEN WE
STILL ARE FACING THESE
CHALLENGES. BUT I ALSO MUST GAS
IS A CO AUTHOR ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT SENATOR YOU DO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION THERE
ARE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT HAD
COME UP AS THIS IS MOVED TO THE
PROCESS THAT DO DROUGHT
CONCERNS- AND I KNOW I HAVEN'T.
TALKED TO YOU PREVIOUSLY ABOUT
IT OBVIOUSLY AS THINGS MOVE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
IN THE EVAN FLOW SOMETIMES
THESE BILLS MOVE OVER- FROM
HOUSE TO HOUSE RATHER QUICKLY
AND RAPIDLY. IN DUE TO THE
COVERED RESTRICTIONS WE HAVEN'T
REALLY BEEN ABLE TO BE FACE TO
FACE BECAUSE WE JUST OPENED
THIS WEEK- BUT I'M MORE THAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU MOVING
FORWARD I AM GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY- BUT IT. BUT AS A
FRIEND AND A COLLEAGUE WHO DOES
CARE ABOUT THIS- WE HAVE TO GET
THIS ONE RIGHT. UP TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS A SOLID FUNDING
FORMULA. AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
WITH THE MASSIVE BUDGET
INCREASE THAT WE'VE SEEN- WHEN
WE WERE EXPECTING A RECESSION
TO SEE A- HUGE SURPLUS. WE
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THIS
FUNDING SITUATION IS SET IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU FURTHER ON
THIS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
I'M LET ME JUST ADDRESS THE
FUNDING ISSUE- UNDER PROP TWO
EIGHTEEN AS THE SENATOR HAS
SAID WE CAN'T HAVE- A- QUILLEN
OF THE CARE PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE FOR UTILITIES FOR. BECAUSE
UNDER PROP TWO EIGHTEEN
EVERYBODY PAYS THEIR OWN WAY
THERE'S NO WAY TO SET UP
PROGRAM THE OTHER QUESTION IS
AND THIS IS WHAT ART WAS
WORRIED ABOUT IS THAT WE COULD
PRODUCE A TAX. I'M PUTTING IN
THE BILL- THAT WE'RE NEVER
GOING TO HAVE ANY KIND OF TAX-
IS NOT FEASIBLE BECAUSE A PRE
AT THE NEXT- LEGISLATURE COULD
OVERRULE IT THIS IS A AN
AMENDMENT THAT THEY'RE ASKING
FOR WHICH SIMPLY. WOULD BE
USELESS ARE THE NEXT LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATION- DOES SIMPLY OVERLY
SO- I DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING
THE OTHER THING IS TO GET ANY
KIND OF TAX INCLUDING THE KIND
OF TAX THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT-
IT WOULD REQUIRE ANOTHER VOTE
SO AGAIN THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH TODAY AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR. THERE
IS NO WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT
FIRST OBJECTION. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE. OKAY OF THE
SENATOR PERHAPS IN YOUR CLOTHES
YOU COULD TALK ABOUT. THE OTHER
TWO AMENDMENTS ONE IS TO HAVE A
SIMPLER- FUND A SIMPLER-
DETERMINATION OF HOW THE
FUNDING IS. SPENT AND THE OTHER
IS- THAT THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN
THE- CARE PROGRAM WHICH I DO
NOT. WHAT ARE YOU ADDRESS THOSE
TWO HOURS ARE SEVEN STRUCTURE
SURE. SO YEAH THE FIRST ONE IS
THE FIRST ONE OKAY IN THE
SECOND ONE THAT THEY BRING UP.
IS THAT THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
CARE PROGRAM IS- PROPERLY SET
UP. SO THAT THEY THINK THAT ARE
ON CARE SHE BE ON THE IS A SAN
WHAT THE SAYING WELL IF YOU'RE
NOT PREPARED TO ANSWER THAT NOW
THAT'S ALSO I CAN I PER THE
CHAIR AT THE YOU MEMBERS FOR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS YOU ALL THE
SIMPLE DETERMINATION I BOUGHT
REAL WILLING TO LOOK AT THAT
SOME SIMPLY DOES OKAY AND WE
AND I HEARD- THIS TALK BRING UP
THEY WHAT WE JUST SPREAD THE
SOUL ALL OVER EVERYBODY AN-
AND MAKE IT EASIER. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME I WANT TO FIND OUT
WHAT THE COSTS ARE OF DOING IT
THE WAY IT'S SET UP IN THE BILL
BECAUSE WE MIGHT WANT TO CHANGE
THE STANDARD IN TERMS OF- YOU
KNOW HOW YOU KNOW WHAT 2100% OF
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVELOR
YOU KNOW EVEN GO HIGHER LOOK
IT'S- BECAUSE A BUDGET
CONSIDERATIONS WE HAVE TO MAKE
TOUGH DECISIONS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THERE MAY NOT
BE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO TAKE
CARE OF EVERYBODY AND SO-
TAKING CARE OF NOBODY IS NOT AN
ANSWER AND SO WE GOT TO DO WHAT
WE CAN DO SO I WILL I WILL LOOK
AT THAT AND WE WILL- YOU KNOW
IF THERE'S A WAY OF BEEN
DEBILITATING THAT SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE A SLIDING SCALE OR
MODIFY IT IN THE FUTURE WITHOUT
COMING BACK TO A LEGISLATURE
RUNNING ANOTHER BILL CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO LOOK AT THAT. ABOUT
THE CARE PROGRAM IF THE CARE
PROGRAM DOESN'T WORK THEN WE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHY IT
DOESN'T WORK AND WHAT WE NEED
TO DO TO MAKE IT RIGHT SO- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT PER
SHEET THE QUESTIONS OKAY SO
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
ARE PROVIDING- AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE FOR DRINKING WATER
AND WATER SERVICES. IN THE SAME
MANNER WE DO FOR ENERGY
SERVICES. IS SOMETHING I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. I UNDERSTAND
THIS IS A COP. PROGRAM THAT.
THE SENATOR IS CREATING. AND
THAT THERE WILL LIKELY BE
CONTINUED DIALOGUE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS-
PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF I OR MY
COMMITTEE STAFF YOU CAN HELP. I
THIS IS SOMETHING WHICH I AM
VERY PLEASED THAT THE SENATOR
BROUGHT UP. AND I REQUEST THAT
COMMITTEE TO TAKE THIS BILL AND
VOTE ON HIGH. ALL RIGHT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS S. B. TWO TWO TWO DODD
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
UTILITIES AND ENERGY. CORK BY
CORK HI SMITH. SMITH NO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I POWER QUE
HAN OUR QUE HAN HI DALLY.
GALLIANO CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN I MATHIS. MATHIS I WOULD
HAVE TO G. MURATSUCHI I. SEVEN
SO WE HAVE SEVEN ICE SET UP
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT FROM WHAT
WE HAVE EVERYONE HERE I'D
APPRECIATE IF WE WOULD JUST GO
THROUGH THE PREVIOUS BELL.
CENTRE YOU MAY COME FORWARD IF
YOU LIKE- IF YOU COULD GO
THROUGH THE PREVIOUS BILL AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
EVERYONE HERE. SO I'M THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE CURRENTLY
ARE. FIVE ZERO. OUR QUE HAN OUR
QUE HAN HI HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI
MATHIS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
MATHIS HI MURATSUCHI WHAT I TO
XII OKAY SO WE HAVE NINE ON
THAT WE GOT- THIS IS ITEM ONE
SB THIRTY SEVEN CORTES A WE'RE
CURRENTLY I HAVE FOUR TWO. OUR
CAN OUR QUE HAN HI MATHIS
MATHIS NO MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO
GI SO THAT BRINGS IT TO A WE DO
HAVE A SIX VOTE TO GET OUT ALL
RIGHT VERY GOOD SENATOR PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
I'M NOT SURE IF WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM WAS A CRISTINA
GARCIA SECOND BY MR HOLDEN.
CENTER GONZALEZ- DRINKING WATER
CONSOLIDATION S. B. FOUR OH
THREE I THINK WE'RE READY WE'RE
ALL DONE ALL RIGHT NOW GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIRED THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR- THE
WONDERFUL ANALYSIS AHEAD OF
PRINCE TODAY TO PRESENT SB FOUR
ZERO THREE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
STATE WATER AUTHORITIES. WITH
AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO HELP
CALIFORNIA FINALLY REALIZED THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO FIX SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED SB EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
PROVIDE OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
ORDER MANDATORY CONSOLIDATIONS.
FOR WATER SYSTEMS THAT SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
CONSISTENTLY FAIL TO PROVIDE
SAFE DRINKING WATER WELL THIS
AUTHORITY IS IMPORTANT IN THE
STATE'S SAFE DRINKING WATER
EFFORTS IT CAN ONLY BE USED IN
SITUATIONS WHERE THE DAMAGE IS
ALREADY DONE. THE SYSTEM IS
ALREADY PROVIDING UNSAFE WATER
WE NEED PREVENTATIVE AND
PROACTIVE MEASURES NOW SB FOUR
ZERO THREE PROVIDES A PROACTIVE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM BY
EXPANDING UPON SB EIGHTY EIGHT
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY TO
APPLY TO WATER SYSTEMS WITH
LESS THAN THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
CONNECTIONS. THAT SERVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
ARE AT RISK OF FAILING.
CONSOLIDATION IS AN EFFECTIVE
TOOL AND APPROVING ACCESS TO
SAFE WATER BECAUSE A LARGER
CONSOLIDATED SYSTEMS ARE
GENERALLY MORE RELIABLE SAFE
AND EFFICIENT. MEMBERS THE
WATER BOARD'S RECENTLY REACHED
RELEASED TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DRINKING WATER NEEDS OVER
ASSESSMENT IDENTIFIED OVER SIX
HUNDRED SYSTEMS THAT ARE AT
RISK OF FAILING AND DETERMINE
THAT ONE THIRD OF THOSE.
ASSESSED DOMESTIC WELLS ARE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY THOUSAND
WELLS WERE CLASSIFIED AS HIGH
RISK. THIS IS WHY WE MUST ASK
ASK ACT NOW IT'S GIVE ME.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY
HAVE BLANCA ESQUIVEL POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ABLE CREWS FOR A RESIDENTS
OF TO LOUISVILLE CALIFORNIA-
WHO WILL BE IN A TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ON SB FOUR OH THREE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE PHONE
MODERATOR- WE'D. NOW LIKE TO
HEAR FROM BLANCA. AS ON. THE
LEADERSHIP CAL FOR JUSTICE
SUSTAINABILITY- PLEASE- PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. GOOD
MORNING SCHERING COMMITTEE ON
CASCO BAY IS ON THE POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NONPROFIT WORKING ALONGSIDE
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND THE COACHELLA VALLEY
AND WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR OF SB
FOUR OH THREE. TO MANY SMALL
WATER SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIAN
HOUSEHOLDS ARE STRUCK BY
DOMESTIC WELLS IN IRAQ RISK OF
WERE ALREADY FAILING TO DELIVER
SAFE WATER ISSUES RANGE FROM
ELEVATED DRINKING WATER
CONTAMINANTS TO BEING AT RISK
OF NOT FEELING. WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY ARE ONE. AWAY FROM
HAVING ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER IN THE HOME. WAITING ON
EMERGENCY TO OCCUR IF YOU TAKE
ACTION IS INEFFICIENT BELIEVES
MANY FAMILY THAT. TAKING ACTION
NOW ELIMINATES TRUST AND
FAMILIES THE STRAIN ON STATE
RESOURCES THE PATENT TO PROVIDE
COFFEE BOTTLED WATER. AND
INSTALL WATER TANKS IF WE WANT
ANYTHING DURING THE
FUNDAMENTALS THE IMPORTANCE OF
CORRECTIVE ACTION TO ENSURE
COMMUNITY PREPAREDNESS IN TIMES
OF EMERGENCY. SB FOUR THREE
BILLS ON SPD EIGHT BY ALLOWING
CONSOLIDATIONS QUESTION TO
BEGIN LED BY COMMUNITIES MOST
AT RISK INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR
EMERGENCY TO HAPPEN. IF PASSED
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WILL HAVE A TOOL
TO IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS AND
FACILITATE CONSOLIDATION IF
IT'S A VIABLE OPTION FOR
COMMUNITY SERVICE RIGHT BY NOT
RISK WATER SYSTEM OR DOMESTIC
WELL. AND THE COMMUNITIES WHICH
TO PURSUE THIS OPTION THIS BILL
IS ALSO INCLUDES A THOROUGH
PUBLIC PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES ENGAGED IN THE
CONCERNS AND PRIORITIES ARE
KICKING INTO ACCOUNT. THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER TODAY AND
WOULD BENEFIT YOU MENTALLY
TREMENDOUSLY FROM THIS BILL.
THAT'S BEEN BUILT ON
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP BY
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER. RESPECTFULLY. URGE YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. WELL
NOW HERE FROM. A BELL CREW
RESIDENT OF TO LEAVE- PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR TESTIMONY. HI
MY NAME IS STABLE CRUZ I AM
FROM ILLEGAL SENATE BILL WATER
HAS BEEN HIGH LEVEL OF THANKS
BYE HOLDEN PROGRAM. THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN WE NEED TO
CONNECT BUT DEFINITELY TIME
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND ONE.
THANK YOU CITY COUNCIL DID NOT
WANT TO GO ON HOLIDAY WITH THE
BILL. ADD ACTIVATE DELIVERED BY
THE COUNTY TO DRINK BAKER
COOPER. BECAUSE WE HAVE TO BUY
ADDITIONAL WATER OUT OF POCKET
AND ADDITIONAL BECAUSE THE
WATER SUPPLY BUT THE- COUNTY IS
NOT ENOUGH. THERE ARE SIX
PEOPLE IN OUR HOUSEHOLD. K.
CAN'T BE EXPECTED TO RELY ON
BOTTLED WATER THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND THE STATE. ALL
THAT I DID I REASON I SUPPORT
SB FOUR ZERO THREE. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
I DO NOT SEE ANYONE NOW COMING
TO THE MICROPHONE HERE SO WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT IN
THE ROOM- WE WILL NEXT GO TO
THE- TWO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANTHONY TANNER HELLO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
BETTER SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION- WILL BE FIRST-
MISTER TANNER HELD PLEASE
PROCEED. MORNING AND THANK YOU
CHAIR NUMBERS- CSTA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES SB PORT
THREE UNLESS IT'S AMENDED AND
THEN LET ME START OF BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF OF THE SPONSORS FOR THEIR-
INSISTENT WILLINGNESS TO
DIALOGUE AND DISCUSS THESE
ISSUES WITH OUR MEMBERSHIP. AND
HEAR US OUT- WELL WE APPLAUD
THE INTENT OF THE MEASURE AND
OF COURSE SHARE THE- UNIVERSAL
OF LIABLE SAFE DRINKING WATER
FOR EVERYONE- THE BILL HAS SOME
DEFICIENCIES BUT WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ADDRESS. OUR MEMBERS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE PUBLIC
AGENCIES WITH ELECTED BOARDS
PLEASE DISTRICTS ARE CREATED BY
THE VOTER AND HELD ACCOUNTABLE
BY THE BOAT. THERE LIKE TO
BOARD MEMBERS LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITY DRINK THE SAME WATER
AND PAY THE SAME RATES AS THEIR
CONSTITUENTS. AND CERTAINLY
WANT SAY FLYABLE FORTY DRINKING
WATER FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ARE SUBJECT TO THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE'VE COME
TO EXPECT FROM ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUT GETS BROWN
ACTOR. PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
TRANSPARENCY RATEPAYER
PROTECTIONS. UNFORTUNATELY AS
PEOPLE ARE THREE TREATS NEWS
LOCAL ELECTED AGENCIES IS THE
SAME AS A PRIVATE SYSTEM ARE
FOR PROFITS IS. BOB VASSALLO OF
THE ADDRESS WATER SYSTEMS ARE
NOT SPECIAL DISTRICT PUBLIC
AGENCIES- AND ACCORDING TO THE
STATE WATER BOARDS RECENT NEEDS
ASSESSMENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS
REPRESENT OUR THIRTY NINE OUT
OF THE SIX HUNDRED SEVENTEEN
NAMES ADDRESS SYSTEMS. IN OUR
MEMBERS EXPERIENCE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ARE OFTEN USING
STUDENTS HOPING TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES ABOUT NEIGHBORING
SYSTEM. AND WITH APPROPRIATE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE OUR MEMBERS ARE READY TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK AND
BEING PART OF THE SOLUTION.
HOWEVER WHAT WE OPPOSE IS
INCREASINGTHE AUTHORITY- AND
I'M ELECTED STATE BOARD TO OVER
RULE- LOCAL ACTION. DULY
ELECTED BOARD AND POTENTIALLY
EVEN GIVE I COMMUNITIES
PUBLICLY OWNED ASSETS TO A
PRIVATE ENTITY AND THERE'S NO
RECOURSE FOR THE BUILDER WHO
CREATED THAT. AGENCY IN THE
CASE OF PUBLIC AGENCIES WITH
ELECTED BOARDS A DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS ALREADY EXISTS TO THE
CORTESE KNOCKS HERTZBERG ACT-
AND THAT'S THE WAY TO WORK WITH
THESE PUBLIC AGENCIES ON WAY. I
RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF LOCAL
VOTER. AS CSKA SHARED
AMENDMENTS OF THE AUTHOR AND
OTHERS- THAT WILL THAT WE HOPE
WILL PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
LOCAL VOTERS- WITHIN EXISTING
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. WHILE STILL
ESTABLISHING THE NEW LAST WEEK
FOR THREE PROCESS FOR THOSE
RESIDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SAME DEMOCRATIC
PROTECTIONS. ARE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS DON'T INHIBIT PUBLIC
AGENCIES FROM RECEIVING AND
HELPING NEIGHBORING WATER
SYSTEMS SOME CLOSING WITH ACT
PASSED THE STATE COULD HELP
ASSESS. AND EMPOWER OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
SERVED BY THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
SO THEY CAN MAINTAIN OWNERSHIP
AND GOVERNANCE OF THEIR OWN
LOCAL WATER SYSTEMS. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS-
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIND A WAY TO
REACH OUR MUTUAL GOALS. BALLS
STONE EXPECTING THESE
DEMOCRATIC. INSTITUTE AND THE
SELF DETERMINED. OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL THREE TIME. THE YOU NET
WE'LL HEAR FOR C. TAR ON BEHALF
OF THE- OF CAN WATER AGENCY.
ACWA ARE PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU CHAIR QUIRK IN MEMBERS
CINDY TECH WITH AQUA AQUA DOES
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON AS BEFORE THREE WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT SENATOR
GONZALEZ HAS MADE TO DATE WE
STILL HAVE TWO ISSUES WITH THE
BILL. THE FIRST ISSUE IS THAT
WERE OKAY WITH THE PROPOSED
CONSOLIDATION AT THE READY FOR
THE ADDRESS PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
BUT WE THINK THAT THE PROPOSED
CONSOLIDATION AUTHORITY FOR AT
RISK DOMESTIC WELLS IS
PREMATURE AND SHOULD BE
DELETED. FONG THE STATE WATER
BOARD DID JUST RELEASED THAT
NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT THE OFFER
AUTHORED REFERENCED IN IN THAT
DOCUMENT WHEN THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE WORK IDENTIFYING THE
AT RISK WELLS OR THE HIGH RISK
WELLS THEY SAY THE- THE STATE
WATER BOARD STAFF STATE. THAT
THAT DUE TO THE LACK OF DATA
FROM ACTUAL STATE SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS AND DOMESTIC WELLS IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PRECISELY
DETERMINE THE COUNT OF THE AT
RISK WELLS. ON THEY KNOW THAT
THEY USE- PROXY DATA AND
ASSUMPTIONS AND THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT THEY HAVE NOT THEY THEY'RE
NOT USING INFORMATION THAT'S
BASED ON AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
COMPLIANCE OF ANY. INDIVIDUAL
WELL OUR SYSTEM. SO IT'S REALLY
STE. ND WE DON'T IT FALL.
AUTHORITY SHOULD BE BASED N A
SPECULATIVE APPROACH. SO THAT'S
THE FIRST ISSUE- THE WATER
BOARD BY THE WAY THEY'RE GOING
TO WORK ON IMPROVING THE DATA
AND REFINING THAT RISK
ASSESSMENT AND THAT'S GREAT BUT
RIGHT NOW THAT THE STORY WEEKS
PREMATURE. SO ON THE SECOND
ISSUE WITH THE PUBLIC PROCESS
ISSUE THE BILL NOW HAS A GOOD
PUBLIC PROCESS STEP THAT THE
POTENTIALLY SUBSUME WATER
SYSTEM- COULD PROVIDE COMMENTS
THAT THE SYSTEM IS NOT AT RISK.
AND IF THE SYSTEM DID SO THE
WATER BOARD WOULD BE REQUIRED
DURING A PUBLIC MEETING TO YOU
KNOW CONSIDER THAT INFORMATION.
IN IN THEIR DECISION MAKING. WE
SUGGEST EXPANDING THAT NEW
PROCESS STEP TO ADDITIONALLY
ALLOW THE POTENTIALLY RECEIVING
SYSTEM WHICH WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY THE
ACTION. TO PROVIDE SUCH
COMMENTS THAT THE SUBSUMED BOND
SYSTEM IS NOT AT RISK- OR THAT
YOU KNOW SYSTEM WELLS ARE NOT
AT RISK AND THEN OF COURSE THE
DECISION WOULD BE UP TO THE
STATE WATER BOARD THAT WE THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PUBLIC
PROCESS STEP TO ADD. SO THAT
ANY- CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY AND
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION. OF THESE ISSUES
THANK YOU. EXCELLENT THANK YOU
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD HEAR FROM
AQUA. I'LL JUST MAKE A COMMENT
WHAT THE BOARD IS DOING IS IT'S
LOOKING AT AREAS WHICH ARE
KNOWN TO HAVE CONTAMINATION SO
WITH. THE SITE IS NEAR- ST
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK WHICH
IS LEAKED- THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT SYSTEM THE
SYSTEM IS STILL THE- PEOPLE
USING THE WELL. ARE STILL
ACTIVE. ABLE TO CHALLENGE THAT.
AND SHOW THAT IT IS WORTHWHILE
SO THAT'S THE FIRST OBJECTION-
THE SECOND ONE I'LL ASK THE-
AUTHOR TO DISCUSSION OR CLOSE-
THE R. I'M JUST GOING TO SAY A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT AND ASK AFTER
RISK SYSTEMS WE'RE TALKING HERE
ABOUT MAJOR PROBLEMS- ALREADY
THE BOARD CAN DEAL WITH-
FAILING SYSTEMS. UP WHAT DOES
IT MEAN TO HAVE AN ACT AT RISK
SYSTEM SO DETERMINING WHICH
SYSTEMS ARE AT RISK IS A VERY
COMPLEX RECENT PROCESS THAT THE
WATER BOARD UCLA DEVELOPED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE RISK
ASSESSMENT METHODOLOGY ARE
WHICH IS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE NEEDS ASSESSMENT-
AND- ONE IN PERSON AND FOR
PUBLIC WOMEN ARE WE SHOULD GO
WORKSHOPS WERE HELD. IT LOOKS
AT A NUMBER OF RISK INDICATORS
IT HAS THRESHOLDS FOR THOSE
RISKS AND THEN IT DOES SCORES
AND WAITS BUT THE SORT OF THING
WE'RE LOOKING AT. IS AND YOU
KNOW ANY ONE OF THESE I THINK
AS A REASON TO BE CONCERNED
HISTORY OF E. COLI PRESENCE
CREASING THE PRESENCE OF WATER
QUALITY TRENDS TOWARDS- THE
MINIMUM. EXCELLENT CONTAMINANT
LEVEL TREATMENT TECHNIQUES
VIOLATIONS PAST PRESIDENTS. ON
THE LIST MAXIMUM DURATION OF
HIGH POTENTIAL EXPOSURES
PERCENTAGES SOURCES EXPEDIENT-
THE MAXIMUM CONTAMINANT-
ACCESSIBILITY NUMBER OF SOURCES
ABSENCE OF INTER INTER TIES
WATER SOURCE TYPES DROUGHT AND
WATER SHORTAGE RISK CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED GROUNDWATER
BASINS. AFFORDABILITY PERCENT
OF THE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME
THAT YOU HAVE TO PAY
STREAMLINER BILLS AND THE
PERCENT OF SHADOW SO THESE ARE
VERY- AND THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING
AT TO. JUST THE NATURE OF THE-
OUR SYSTEM ITSELF SO THESE ARE
VERY SERIOUS MATTERS AND IF
THEY'RE NOT FIXED NOW WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS RISK OF PEOPLE BEING
POISONED BY THE WATER IN THE
FUTURE. SO IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET TOGETHER THESE-
DISTRICTS SELL THAT- THEY HAVE
ENOUGH ECONOMIES OF SCALE TO
FACE THIS ISSUE ALSO THE STATE
WATER BOARD WILL BE A HAS FUNDS
TO HELP THEM DO THE
CONSOLIDATION SO. AGAIN THIS IS
A VERY SERIOUS MATTER WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ASTERISK
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR- DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE- OKAY
NOW WE CAN GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR ZERO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU TRAIN
MEMBERS WE KEEP HER ID BUT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS JULIET CHRISTIAN SMITH
PUT THE WATER FOUNDATION I'D
ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT I AM A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
AND A DIRECTOR ON THE BOARD OF
A SPECIAL DISTRICT ELECTED I
AM- CALLING TO SUPPORT AS
BEFORE- ST- AND WANTED TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK. POINTS THAT THIS IS A
CRISIS- SITUATION THE ONLY
REASON THIS IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE LOCAL INSTITUTIONS HAVE
FAILED TO SECURE SAFE DRINKING
WATER- AND THE PEOPLE ARE BEING
POISONED BY TOXIC WHAT.THANK
YOU WE JUST GONNA TAKE- NAME.
AND ORGANIZATION AND POSITION-
PLEASE OPERATOR PROCEED FOR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING AGAIN MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON TRITON
TRITON CRISIS. ON BEHALF OF
WATER FOUNDATION AND NEXT GEN
POLICY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
INTEGRITY ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER LONG POVERTY IN FORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF- FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING TURN NUMBERS TRIPLE
GONZALEZ WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION PLANS GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR- SO WE CAN NOW GO
TO MEMBERS MISTER MATHIS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. IN MEMBERS
I'D I FIRST WANT TO GO THROUGH
SOME HISTORY- IN REGARDS TO
SOME OF THE TESTIMONY THAT WAS
GIVEN- IN REGARDS TO SOME OF
THINGS HAPPENING WITHIN MY OWN
DISTRICT THREE IN REGARDS TO
CHILE VILLAIN EXETER- THAT I'VE
WORKED INTIMATELY WITH- FRANKLY
OVER THE LAST SEVEN YEARS AS
WELL AS TOUCH ON THE ASSEMBLY
BILL. THREE THIRTY NINE THE
STATE WATER POLLUTION IS CLEAN
UP. AND ABATEMENT. THAT COUNTS
WHICH IS RECEIVED ZERO FUNDING
FROM OUR STATE BODY SINCE WE
ENACTED IT BACK IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH SPECIFICALLY OF
THAT BILL IS TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR SUCH AREAS. FIRST THE TO
THE BILL CITY OF EXETER. OUR
SITUATION IS A SITUATION VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE FACED WITH
EAST SIDE PORT OF ILL VERSUS
THE CITY OF FORT OF L. THE-
CITY OF EXETER SIMPLY LACKS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE ABILITY.
TO TIE IN A COMMUNITY THAT IS
SEVERAL MILES. AWAY FROM THEM.
SO THE FORCE CONSOLIDATION
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE WE
HAVE WORKED WITH THE COUNTY OF
TULARE WHO HAS JURISDICTION
OVER. THE COUNTY ISLAND OF TO
THE BILL AND THE SUPERVISOR AT
THE TIME WHO WAS SUPERVISOR
KYLER CROCKER WHO IS NO LONGER
SUPERVISOR AND WAS VOTED OUT-
SOME MAY SPECULATE DUE TO HIS
LACK OF ABILITY IN DEALING WITH
CERTAIN THINGS- IN HIS IN THE
ACCESSIBILITY ON CERTAIN ISSUES
SUCH AS THIS- BUT I WILL NOT
SPECULATE TO WHY VOTERS CHOSE
TO REPLACE HIM WITH NOW
SUPERVISOR LARRY MCCARTY. I
KNOW BOTH INDIVIDUALS AND
THEY'RE BOTH GOOD MEN. THE
SITUATION THOUGH IS THE FACT
THAT THE COUNTY DEALS WITH THE
SEWAGE TREATMENT OF THE TWO
LEGAL COMMUNITY THEY DO WITH
THE BILLING THEY DEAL WITH ALL
OF THAT. THE PROBLEM THERE IS
THAT MANY OF THE HOMES WITHIN
THE TO REVEAL COMMUNITY. STILL
RELY ON SEPTIC TANK ISSUES. SO
THE COUNTY DEALS WITH THAT AND
DEALS WITH THEIR SEPTIC THEY
HAVE A SPECIAL DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY FOR SEPTIC ISSUES
THEY ALSO HAVE A SPECIAL
DISTRICT BILLION WITH THEIR
WATER IN THERE TO WELLS THAT
THEY HAVE THAT HAVE
CONTAMINATION ISSUES PARTIALLY
IN PART TO THE FAILING SEPTIC
ISSUES. AGAIN HAVE WORKED ON
THIS INTIMATELY FOR SEVEN YEARS.
THE ISSUE THEN BECOMES IF WE DO
RUN A LINE. TO THE SAID CITY IN
IN THIS ISN'T SPECIFIC JUST FOR
THE TO LOUISVILLE THIS IS THE
SAME STORY ACROSS OUR STATE. IS
THAT WE HAVE COUNTY ISLANDS.
THAT SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD. WE
ALSO HAVE COUNTY ISLANDS THAT
IN INTO THE BILL'S HISTORY THE
PAST. FOLKS WHO RAN THEIR WATER
SYSTEM FRANKLY. IS THERE TO
SHOW THEY THEY'RE SIMPLY JUST
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY TO DO IT
BECAUSE THE MONEY THEY DID AT.
GOBLIN AWAY DUE TO CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. AGAIN THIS ISN'T A
STORY JUST TO THIS SMALL
COMMUNITY OF TOTALLY THE- NOW
DO YOU HAVE THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE A CITY YOU HAVE A COUNTY
ISLAND IT. LOGICAL THAT THEY
TI<c.cyan>. WHO PAYS FOR IT THE</c>
FACT IS UNDER CURRENT UTILITY
CODE MEMBERS AND SENATOR THAT
IF YOU ADD THAT ADDITIONAL LINE.
THE NEW PEOPLE TIED INTO THAT
LINE ARE NOW FINANCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING FOR SAID
LINE. THAT'S UTILITY COAT AS IT
CURRENTLY STANDS. CHAU THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT IS THAT THE
SMALL COUNTY ISLANDS SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD THAT ADDITIONAL
COST BECAUSE THEY ALREADY CAN'T
AFFORD THE WATER SYSTEMS THAT
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO GET FIXED
WE HAVE SEEN THIS ON THE MISTER
SALAS IS DISTRICT IN MR
ARAMBULA IS DISTRICT- IF YOU
TAKE ANY OF THE WATER TOWARDS
ACROSS THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY-
NOW U. S. SENATOR ALEX VIDEO
ACTUALLY BEEN WITH HIM OUT AT
SOME WE HAVE SEEN WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS PUT IN TO DO A
ARSENIC ISSUES TO DEAL WITH
NITROGEN ISSUES TO DEAL WITH
THE TOXICITY ISSUES. THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES FACE AND THE FACT
IS MANY OF THESE PLANTS ARE
MOTHBALLED BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY ARE PUT
INTO SERVICE CANNOT AFFORD. TO
PAY TO RUN THE TREATMENT PLANTS
AND THEY CANNOT AFFORD THE
WATER THAT THE TREATMENT PLANTS
PRODUCE FOR THEIR HOMES AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WHICH LEADS ME
TO THE POINT. WITH ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE THIRTY NINE WHICH I
AUTHORED AND IT WAS NOT MY
FIRST ATTEMPT WE TOOK THREE
YEARS. TO BUILD THIS OUT FROM
MY FRESHMAN YEAR INTO MY
SOPHOMORE YEAR. IN WHAT THIS
ACCOUNT DOES IS IT LITERALLY
PAYS FOR THE TREATMENT PLANTS.
IN FROM THE BILL TAX I TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY DURING THE
DISCUSSION TO PULL IT UP. IF WE
GO DOWN INTO SECTION. TWO WHICH
DEALS WITH THE ELIGIBILITY.
PUBLIC AGENCIES TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS NONPROFITS
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS. AND IT
GOES ON AND ON WE WROTE THIS IN
FINE TOOTH THIS. MANY MEMBERS
HERE HELPED ME WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. BECAUSE AS A
JUNIOR REPUBLICAN TEMPERATURE
AND HE MEGA MAJORITY DEMOCRAT
HOUSE IT TOOK ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
BUT AGAIN. THERE HAS BEEN ZERO
FUNDING PUT INTO THE ACCOUNT
THAT WAS DESIGNED. TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THESE
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES THE
SMALL COUNTY ISLAND COMMUNITIES
LIKE TO LEAVE. NO MONEY. IN OUR
STATE BUDGET YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR I PUT IN THE BUDGET
REQUEST EVERY SINGLE YEARS WELL.
I KNOW SENATOR HER TITLE I KNOW
SOME OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
CAUCUS MEMBERS HAVE ASKED FOR
FUNDING IN THAT ACCOUNT. IT HAS
NOT HAPPENED. THE CONCERN. IN
YOU ALL BUT I THE HISTORY IS
IMPORTANT HERE. THIS BILL THE
FORCED CONSOLIDATION OF THESE
DISTRICTS THERE ARE A LOT OF
PIECES THAT HAVE TO BE TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT HERE. WHO FUNDS IT
HOW DOES THE BILLING METRICS
GET SET UP. ARE WE
INCORPORATING JUST THE WATER OR
WE INCORPORATING THE SEWAGE IF
THE SEWAGE IS ALREADY THERE IN
A BILLING MECHANISM IS THERE
SAY WITH THE COUNTY DO THEY
THEN GET JURISDICTION OVER THAT.
AND ARE THEY GOING TO TAKE IN
ACCOUNT THE ENTIRE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE WHICH THEY OUGHT TO.
BECAUSE IF WE FORCE THE
CONSOLIDATION OF A SMALL SYSTEM
WE HAVE A SEWAGE SYSTEM
DISTRICT ON TOP OF IT. NOW
CONSOLIDATED WITH THE CITY
SYSTEM THAT'S ALREADY DEALING
WITH CITY AND SEWAGE. BECAUSE
THOSE INFRASTRUCTURES HAVE TO
BE LOOKED AT AS WELL BECAUSE
NOW YOU'RE ASKING A STRUGGLING
SMALL CITY. WHO ALREADY HAS
FUNDING ISSUES. THEY THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT I AM SET DOWN WITH
THE CITY MANAGER NEXT TERM
ENTITLEMENT AT THE FOR A COUPLE
YEARS ON THIS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THE MECHANISMS WE KNOW THE
COUNTY NEEDS TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PART OF THIS. WE KNOW THERE
ARE MULTIPLE DIFFERENT PIECES
THAT HAVE TO BE DONE IN
THREADED THAT NEEDLE JUST RIGHT
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THESE
THINGS WORK. AND WE HAVE TO BE
VERY. THOUGHTFUL. I'M THINKING
ABOUT IT'S NOT JUST
CONSOLIDATING WATER. IT'S WATER
IN SEWAGE TOGETHER WATER
WAS IN THE HOUSE IT'S GOT TO
COME OUT OF THE HOUSE IT'S GOT
TO GO TO A TREATMENT PLAN HAS
GOT TO GO THROUGH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT LITTLE STEPS. THAT
FRANKLY I DON'T SEE IN THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. I'LL BE
MORE THAN HAPPY SENATOR TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS. I THINK IS BE
EITHER TAKE A POSITIVE AND HOLD
BACK MUCH COMPAQ LATER WE'D
HAVE TIME IN THIS SESSION TO
MAKE THIS BETTER BUT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE
RIGHT AND I'D LOVE TO HELP YOU
WITH THAT I LOVE THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL VISIT CURRENTLY IS
MEMBERS I ASK YOU ALL FOR AN
OVER. THANK YOU- THANK YOUS ARE.
VERY MUCH- OTHER COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT I'LL JUST
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT- THREE GOOD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BROUGHT UP IT IS UP TO
THE WATER BOARD TO DECIDE ON
THESE THINGS I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
CONSOLIDATING THE SEWER SYSTEM.
THAT I CAN ANSWER BUT AS FAR
AS- FOR EXAMPLE THE ENTIRE TIME.
IT WOULD NOT MAKE SENSE TO.
CONSOLIDATE UNLESS THERE WERE
AN INTERTIDAL BOARD HAS THE
ABILITY TO PAY FOR THAT INNER
TIE SO I DON'T THINK THEY WOULD
CONSOLIDATE WITHOUT SPENDING
THE MONEY TO KEEP THE SYSTEM SO
THAT THEY WOULD ACTUALLY BE
CONSOLIDATED SO I THINK THAT
THAT PART IS TAKEN CARE OF- IF
YOU'RE ANYONE ELSE A YES MISTER
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU I WANT
TO. THANK CENTER FOR YOUR BILL
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL-
BUT I ALSO WANT TO THANK A CELL
NUMBER MATHIS. YOU KNOW AND
YOUR YOUR COMMENT ABOUT YOUR
YOUR- EDUCATING ME ABOUT THE
HISTORY. OF THIS ISSUE THAT
YOU'VE BEEN WORK BY CHAMPIONING
FOR YEARS I APPRECIATE THAT I
PARTICULARLY NOTICED THE- YOU
KNOW YOUR YOUR YOUR TALK ABOUT
THAT SOME OF THE- THE-
CRIMINAL- CORRUPT ACTIVITIES
AND IT IN THAT- APPEAR TO BE
PART OF THAT HISTORY AND- I
KNOW THAT THAT'S THIS REMINDS
ME HE I AND- YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S A- YOUR HISTORY OR- YOU
KNOW THE WORK THAT MS CARS HE
IS DONE AND HER- DISTRICT AND-
IN SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES. I
MEAN YOU KNOW. THIS- YOU KNOW
OF A PREVALENT TOO PREVALENT
HISTORY OF- OF CORRUPTION- IN
THESE WATER- YOU KNOW. SYSTEM
OR WATER DISTRICTS AND THE
PUBLIC WATER DISTRICTS I MEAN
I. I LISTEN TO THE SPECIAL
DISTRICT- ASSOCIATIONS-
COMMENTS YOU KNOW. ASKING US TO
RESPECT BE LOCALLY ALL ELECTED
TO- WATER DISTRICTS- BUT- I
HAVE TO SAY THAT- IT JUST. I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S THE-
THE LACK OF PUBLIC SCRUTINY
THAT THAT YOU KNOW TO HOLD
THESE. LOCALLY ELECTED WATER
DISTRICT- REPRESENTATIVES
ACCOUNTABLE- IF THAT'S JUST NOT
HAPPENING. BUT YOU KNOW IT IT
IT SEEMS TO ME TO COME BACK TO
THE BILL THAT- THAT YOUR YOUR
BILL PERHAPS WILL HELP.
CONSOLIDATE THOSE AT RISK-
SYSTEMS THAT THAT THAT MAY BE-
OVERSEEN BY- BY BY BY SOME OF
THESE CORRUPT- WATER DISTRICTS-
TO HELP INSURE YOU KNOW THE
SAFE- DELIVERY OF WATER TO ALL
pSTATE OF CALIFORNIA- YOU KNOW I
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT
THE LACK OF FUNDING AND HOW
YOU'VE BEEN FIGHTING FOR. FOR
MORE FUNDING TO SUPPORT THESE
CONSOLIDATIONS BUT YOU KNOW
THAT THERE SEEMS TO BE AN
ONGOING ISSUE I YOU KNOW I
WOULD. I LIKE TO HEAR THE
SENATOR. YOU KNOW IT TOO TO SEE
IF SHE HAS ANY COMMENTS AS TO
WHETHER THIS BILL WILL HELP.
YOU KNOW ADDRESS SOME OF THAT-
TO PREVALENT- EXAMPLES OF
CORRUPTION IN AND WATER
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO RESPOND AND-
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ASSEMBLY MMBER GARCIA AND I
SHARE THESAME DISTRICT IN
SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES SO I'M
WELL AWARE OF THE ISSUES IS TO
CORRUPTION AS TOO. UNSAFE
DRINKING WATER AND THIS IS
EXACTLY WHY WE NEED THIS TO
LEAVE BILL IS PART OF THE SIX
HUNDRED AT RISK- SYSTEMS. AND
SO I WANT TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT NOT JUST SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES BUT PLACES LIKE
YOUR DISTRICT WHERE ONE OF MY
BEST FRIENDS FROM PORTERVILLE
AND TELLS ME ABOUT THE- ISSUES
CONSTANTLY. AND UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- SO. IN WORKING WITH YOU
AND WORKING WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HERE THAT ARE WILLING
TO WORK WITH ME TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO GET THIS RIGHT THIS
JUST BUILD UP SB EIGHTY EIGHT.
IT'S TOO LATE IF WE SAY THAT
IT'S ALREADY FAILED WE HAVE TO
BE PREVENTATIVE WE HAVE TO BE
PROACTIVE. AND SO THIS IS WHY
YOU KNOW UNDER SB TWO HUNDRED
THAT WAS- PLACE THERE IS
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO CORRECT
THESE. ISSUES BUT YOU KNOW YOU
CAN LAUGH OR DISAGREE WITH THAT
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT SO. WITH THAT SAID
YOU KNOW- WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH AWKWARD AS WELL. WE'VE
ADDRESSED 80% OF THEIR ISSUES I
KNOW THAT THEY WANT TO. DELETE
THE DOMESTIC WELLS WHICH I
RESPECTFULLY- DISAGREE WITH.
AND ADD MORE DUE PROCESS WHICH
WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK ON. AT THE
SPECIAL JUST DISTRICTS I THINK
A LOT OF A LOCAL CONTROL
ISSUES. WILL HOPEFULLY BE
WORKED OUT IN AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE'RE HAPPY WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO THAT AS WELL SO.
WITH THAT IF THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO HEAR THEM
BUT YOU KNOW THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOR THAT. THE
WHOLE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALL
RIGHT- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K.
HAND HERE MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER WORK ON THIS I THINK THIS
IS SO CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
WE ARE GETTING AHEAD OF AS YOU
POINT OUT THESE FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS AND PROVIDING CLEAN AND
ACCESSIBLE DRINKING WATER HAS
BEEN THE CENTER OF THE
CONVERSATION DAY FROM YOUR BILL
TO MR DODD'S BILL- AND I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL WORK AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK WHICH
IS CLEARLY SHOWN THROUGH YOUR
COMMENTS AND TIME WHERE WE'VE
GOTTEN ON THIS BILL AND I LOOK
FOR TO BRING IT. THANK YOU.
OKAY- I'LL MAKE ANOTHER COMMENT
AGAIN IN RESPONSE TO THE GOOD
QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS-
AFFORDABILITY IS PART OF THE
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER AND THE
WATER BOARD MUST CONSIDER THAT
MANY CONSOLIDATION EXISTING
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODES ALSO-
HAS LIMITATIONS ON CHARGING
CUSTOMERS MORE. THERE'S ALSO S.
B. TWO HUNDRED FUNDING THAT CAN
PROVIDE MONEY FOR THESE
CONSOLIDATIONS- THEY GET AROUND
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY S. B. TWO
HUNDRED MONEY IS ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION A YEAR
FROM THE GREENHOUSE GAS- FUNDS-
OR GENERAL FUND IF- IF THERE
AREN'T THE MONEY IF THERE ISN'T
THE MONEY FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS FUNDS SO THERE IS MONEY TO
DO THIS THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
STATE THEY HAVE
TO- IN FACT ON THOSE INTERTIDAL
BRING IT TOGETHER. AND THEY DO
HAVE MONEY TO DO IT- SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTES WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH MANY MEMBERS THIS IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT- AND I JUST WANT
TO BUILD OFF THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA IN OUR BACKYARD AND THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO SOUTHEAST
LOS ANGELES LIKE IT IS TO TRULY
BILL IN. PORTER BILL IN AND
MANY PLACES IN CALIFORNIA SO
WITH THAT THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND RESPECT LAST
NIGHT- SO I THINK IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO BRING
THE SYSTEMS- TOGETHER- GIVEN
THE WATER BOARD'S AUTHORITY TO
DO THIS- AND AGAIN IT'S- WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT QUITE SERIOUS. AT
RISK ARE THE ONE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A SYSTEMATIC RISK. WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE POISONED ON
THE WAY TO BECOME FAILING. SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT
THIS- SO I'M ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD- WE CONTINUE
TO. AS YOU SAID OUR WORK ON THE
CONSOLIDATION PROCESS-
CERTAINLY THAT'S ONE OF THE
REQUESTS FROM ATWATER THAT. YOU
SAID YOU WILL DEFINITELY LOOK
INTO. THIS BILL DOES GO TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SO WE HAVE TO
GET IT OUT TODAY- I APPRECIATE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT YOU'D LIKE
TO WAIT ON IT BUT THAT'S NOT
THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS HERE
WE HAVE TO GET IT TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. SO WITH THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND AND
I WOULD LIKE THE SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS THE S.
B. FOUR ZERO THREE GONZALEZ.
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WORK HIGH
COURT HIGHSMITH. SMITH NO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I OUR QUE
HAN. OUR CAN I DALLI. DALLI NO
CRISTINA GARCIA. CRISTINA
GARCIA HI HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI
MATHIS MATHIS NO MORE THAT'S
WHAT SHE WANTED TO GI. WE HAVE
SIX EYES THAT'S OUT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU
EVERYONE- I USE WE HAVE
EVERYONE IS VOTED ON EVERY BILL
SO WE MAY CLOSE THE HEARING.
HEARING HIS CLOTHES.